[Music]
josh is with us in dayton ohio hi josh
how are you
hey how's it going dave how are you
better than i deserve how can i help
well dave i have a little situation man
i keep hesitating on the budget and just
the guy that you were talking to max i'm
like oh my god every word he's saying
about anxiety is me
um here's what i got i have forty four
thousand i think it's about forty four
thousand dollars total debt thirty
thousand student loans fourteen to the
irs i have about seven thousand dollars
in cash and two vehicles that's paid off
and i'm written and my rent is 350. i
need help okay
and are you single
yes why do you have two cars
um over the course of a couple years
i've bought it in ultimate cash i have a
lacrosse with my trans am and i've heard
you before and i got in that a long time
ago and paid off a
mustang i had
i said i'm not going to do that again so
i just paid cash work yeah so what are
these cars worth
uh the lacrosse um it's nice and stacked
out and all that probably about five
thousand and the train exam it's a drop
top 98 probably about nine seven to nine
thousand yeah it's kind of a collectible
yeah okay
all right interesting okay and what is
your hot what's your income sir
uh about 45 to 48 000. okay
all right
well um i always put the irs at the top
of your debt snowball and they would be
no exception here do you have them on an
installment plan on payments
i have nothing i just got a letter
probably about uh a month or so ago
i had missed a couple years of solid
taxes i had a guy that got over on me
about eight grand and
uh i got a letter i didn't know what to
do at that point so you don't the 7000
is their estimate because you've never
filed
no their estimate no i have seven
thousand cash i'm sorry the 14 000 the
14 000 yeah 14 000 is what they yeah
what the letters say about thirteen to
four yeah but that has that's not
reality that's just their guess
they just guessed
if i found this year in the previous two
i didn't so i guess they took the 2013
exactly taxes
so exactly and that doesn't the problem
is you've got to file anyway
yeah and so your first step is to jump
online and find one of our endorsed
local providers for taxes
in your area and go down and get your
taxes filed and then you'll find out
what you really do owe the irs you might
only owe them ten dollars i don't know
what you owe them their guess is just
that it's a guess and it's not even a
good guess it's the irs guess
right you might owe them more i don't
know but you probably
owe them less is my guess
and so i want you to you know scratch
everything together get with a tax
professional and get all of your tax
returns filed and current
failure to file is a criminal act
failure to pay is not
right you do not want them tracking you
down on failure to file you want to get
filed as soon as you can so that's
current right now so
i'm sorry helping
some current on them right now that's oh
yeah
you've already found them this year this
year yes
this year but did you follow the other
two years
yeah i had a amendment where i had all
of them together and i fouled this year
oh i thought you just meant you filed
this year and you didn't file the other
two no i i ended up getting all the
information and that solid at the
beginning of this year okay is that what
created the 14 000 or is that their
guess what i'm thinking yes that's the
letter i got about a month and a half
and when you filed it should have had a
tax number on it that was owed
well it set forth it had 4 000 because
of my dependence of last year that's the
only thing i had at the time so i'm
thinking uh they added that because i
remember it was a eight thousand dollar
bill that i've seen years later uh
earlier by okay but you have your tax
returns
for the last three years have been filed
recently
those those actually have a dollar
amount on them
okay and if that dollar amount doesn't
total 14 then there's a problem
okay so what do i do with the baby steps
if it totals 14 you're gonna give them
this seven thousand six of this seven
immediately and get you at one 000 and
then you're gonna start paying them big
chunks as fast as you can and get them
out of your life
okay they're your number one item on
your baby step two
okay and you just get them out of your
life number one to start with they are
your smallest debt which is good news
but number two it's a freaking irs and
you want them out of your life the
penalties the taxes interest rates
everything and the power that they have
with the irs is just not something you
want to mess with you get your taxes
current you stay current on your taxes
it's too expensive to do otherwise so
just that that's the first thing that's
going to give you a lot of peace
and then we start tearing into the
student loans as fast as we can and then
you're sitting there looking at that
trans am going do i want 9 000 worth of
this stuff gone or do i want to keep
this car and fight my way through it
either one's okay with me but you just
need to ask yourself that question if i
had nine thousand dollars in the middle
of the kitchen table would i throw it at
these debts right now the way i feel
anxious or would i buy a trans am drop
top 98 i might because that's a pretty
sweet car but uh but i might also just
clean up my debts and then pick me up a
car later now is that car got any
sentimental value other than the fact
that's really cool
no
i love it man it's a drop top i grew up
i know
that's what it was you just wanted one
but it wasn't like your first car when
you were 16 or something like that
no yeah i'd probably dump it and get me
one later when i've got some money right
now you're a broke guy that i was
obviously irs you don't need to be
collecting cars that's probably what i
would do now i've got some nice cars but
i didn't have them when i was broke
um and i added them to the to the stable
later on once i got myself under control
and got some wealth
and so yeah i'm probably dumping that
thing and let's get the irs out of your
life and then start working on sally may
give her her eviction notice hold on i'm
gonna send you a copy the book the total
money makeover to help you do all this
stuff this is the dave ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Applause]
[Music]
you